[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you've been
paying attention for the past few years
and if you're watching this show we hope
you are there has likely been a moment
when you realize that reality is not
quite what you thought it was a lot of
the things you assumed were true in fact
are not true they are instead a mirage
they're a web of purpose-built myths
designed to deceive rather than inform
you
you can't really trust your senses
anymore your eyes will lie to you
that's an unnerving thought especially
when you realize that ultimately
vladimir putin is behind it all
russian disinformation is everywhere in
this country it's lurking even within
our own minds it's worse even than adam
schiff told us it was
just last weekend for example thousands
of southwest airlines flights failed to
leave the ground it seemed obvious that
the mass cancellations were a direct
reaction to joe biden's vaccine mandates
they were announced just days before and
then actual southwest pilots appeared to
confirm this
but no
that's just what the kremlin wants you
to think in fact as the authorities
assured us all along it was only the
weather nothing more than a few clouds
calm down america that southwest
airlines story is as fake as hunter
biden's laptop don't let the russians
lie to you people love the vaccine
mandates even the thousands who've been
fired because of them they know
perfectly well how naughty they've been
they need discipline and they're
grateful to get it thank you mr
president may i have another
there is a reason in other words that
joe biden is the single most popular
head of state in american history and
the reason is he's awesome how beloved
is joe biden well let's put it this way
at sporting events across the country
fans are breaking out in cheers for the
white house and its wise and eloquent
leader these are not coordinated
political set pieces astro turf as we
say in washington no
these are spontaneous eruptions of love
one minute you'll be watching a college
football game from the stands the next
minute you'll be overcome with the
desire
the pressing irresistible need to tell
joe biden how great he is
it's like having him go to the bathroom
real bad except better and more
progressive
this is happening ladies and gentlemen
and it's happening everywhere a cresting
tsunami of support for joe biden here's
a sample
[Applause]
it's inspiring when you think about it
joe biden on his first day in office
promised to bring this country together
and now he's actually doing it it
doesn't matter what team you showed up
to root for in your heart you were a joe
biden fan and that is national unity now
not everyone is for this of course to
vladimir putin who hates us for our
freedoms and also because he's russian
this is a threat
loving biden is a thing of beauty so by
definition vladimir putin must destroy
it it's like a sunset a rose garden a
baby's smile it's something lovely that
must be defiled if russia is going to
dominate the world
so in order to corrupt what is good and
beautiful putin has spread the lie that
these expressions of pure devotion to
joe biden are instead
attacks on joe biden vulgar attacks that
include an epithet beginning with f
and sadly a lot of people believe that
russian disinformation is effective
that's why they do it
so thank heaven nbc has been there to
correct that misperception over the past
several years nbc has done maybe more
than any other news organization in this
country to fight the kremlin's
propaganda machine thanks to nbc for
example your doubts about the fairness
of the last election have not only been
settled they're now illegal you're not
allowed to express them ever again
so we can be thankful that there was a
credentialed representative of nbc
sports on hand earlier this month when
fans at a nascar event begin to
celebrate spontaneously celebrate joe
biden
if the nbc lady had not been there you
might very well have misheard what the
crowd said
watch
oh my gosh she's such an
unbelievable moment
brandon you also told me
you can hear the chance from the
crowd
let's go brandon
f joe biden please come on wake up
america that's like looking at the
thriving incredibly robust economy all
around us and concluding there's
inflation settle down vladimir putin
that's ridiculous
what they said and you could hear it
very clearly if you just open your ears
to the truth is let's go brandon
the nbc lady made that very clear not f
joe biden let's go brandon
but who is brandon you ask well just
another happy american who's grateful
for the wise leadership of his
benevolent president in fact brandon is
a newly arrived american part of what we
call the biden generation he's an
undocumented trans haitian migrant now
enrolled thanks to a pell grant as a
film studies major at nyu as well as a
part-time non-binary rights activist and
puppeteer
brandon is the embodiment of the new
american dream where everything's free
but everyone is still angry
just this month thanks to joe biden
brandon got his fourth covid shot that
means he's an incredibly good person far
better than you are and the crowd is
simply celebrating that as grateful
people spontaneously do let's go brandon
let's get a fifth shot let's go brandon
so once you strip away the russian
propaganda it's all pretty obvious and
natural
but it does make you wonder if you pause
for a moment
if the russians are lying about brandon
what else are they lying about and we're
glad you asked they're lying about
hospitals vladimir putin is making up
stories about our hospitals here in the
united states putin claims that our
health care system is collapsing because
of joe biden's vaccine mandates and
that's preposterous
and yet somehow those crafty and
relentless kremlin propagandists have
managed to get that story onto american
television watch this
hospital officials say they still plan
to pause service in the maternity unit
starting saturday
you know we've had 43 resignations
70 of those are in clinical areas
and
unfortunately a number of
the
maternity nurses you know the
professionals who do labor delivery and
postpartum care
are part of that group
so the maternity nurses all left
there'll be no more delivering babies in
that hospital now the russians blame joe
biden for this but the truth is very
different the truth is that this is yet
another heartfelt tribute to joe biden
those nurses left so they can devote
more time to campaigning for joe biden's
re-election in 2024 once again this is
an active love disguised by a foreign
power as an act of contempt
that's happening in a lot of places
ladies and gentlemen not just new york
central maine medical center is one of
the biggest hospitals in the state of
maine it just halted its pediatric and
trauma admissions you want to treat your
child for a disease you've been hurt in
a car accident you can't go there why
well they cited staffing shortages
because of the vaccine mandates
according to a local news outlet quote
the hospital is preparing to potentially
lose hundreds of workers so far 84 staff
members have resigned
this is one hospital
in a smallish town in one state
and they're going to quote lose hundreds
of workers well that's one way to look
at it that's the russian way to look at
it the patriotic way to look at it the
joe biden approved way to look at it is
very different here it is it means
hundreds of new job openings for the
foreign nationals currently streaming
over our southern border there will be
no unemployment crisis for them so in
fact this is a massive win
thanks to the vaccine mandate these
illegal americans will have plenty to do
not just in maine but everywhere in
washington state the spokane spokesman
review just reported that long-term care
facilities could face critical staffing
shortages why vaccine mandates taking
effect october 18th oh
so if you just showed up from another
country without permission to be here
you know what you can do for a living
take the place of someone who moved on
legacy americans in the state of
michigan the head of the largest nursing
homes association said the vaccine
mandates will cause them to quote face
an even greater crisis
or as a good american would put it a
greater opportunity
residents of seattle by the way are
about to have plenty of new
opportunities opportunities to practice
their self-defense skills it's a good
excuse to brush up on that tae kwon do
from fifth grade but you forgot about
those skills time to get them back
the people of seattle are about to
confront a massive shortage of law
enforcement officers why
you guessed it joe biden's vaccine
mandates here's how one local news
station reported it
already short staffed the seattle police
department is preparing for a potential
mass firing of officers starting october
13 the agency will move into what's
called a stage 3 mobilization what the
department's manual says is reserved for
scenarios that have the quote potential
to cause significant harm property
destruction or widespread public fear
354 sworn personnel had not submitted
proof of vaccination as of tuesday that
number dropped to 292 today but still
that's more than 25 percent of all
deployable officers
so we've just given you a snapshot of
what's happening in the country but it's
happening all around the country from
coast to coast and all through the
middle of the country
and it's happening right now
and that means in the coming months at
some point you're going to call
for an emergency or you're going to show
up at the hospital with an injury or
you're going to try to catch an airplane
flight and you will notice that you
can't
because the hospitals the police
departments the fire departments
your airlines none of them work anymore
now joe biden is going to take the blame
for this if the russians have their way
vladimir putin will tell you it's joe
biden's fault
oh no no
it's a tribute to brandon
let's go brandon hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else